do you want to be in a relationship
where the man has no boundaries for you
you're free to do whatever you want yeah
he says you can't do this you can't do
it
no no wait what
i didn't say that i'm saying do you want
to be in a relationship where a man has
no values for you that's a yes or no
question she should have her own values
no all right so you're saying no
so i i would want but we're gonna create
boundaries together i'm not saying oh
like oh do whatever you want to because
at the end of the day like i said you're
you're coming together as a team to
create a bond as a team i understand
that but i'm saying if you're with me
you're finished let her finish okay if
you're
when you come into like terms of the
origin of the relationship because
you're saying that you know they said oh
we want to be together so
we've discussed how we want to establish
our relationship in this you've
discussed no because you're saying
you're saying my my views are
invalidated because you're saying i
can't tell you what to do because that
seems like i'm being uh controlling
trolling but your
your things what you put on me i have to
take fully 100 percent
when the two people start a relationship
they say together what is going to work
for them they create the boundaries
together it's not it's not just going to
be uh i'm your dictator no like i i'm
not saying that the man can't be in
charge like because i
the man should take charge like that's
that will work for me so isn't that
dictatorship no no it's not upset
it's not like okay so okay you want me
to be in charge but you don't want me to
hear you no you know what not there
there's a difference between demanding
every er my every move and i didn't say
i didn't say that i just said you can't
even you're asking me and then you're
not letting me answer no okay okay so
there's a difference between
there's there's a difference between
saying okay babe i think you should do
this and saying nah you're only going to
do this and i'm not letting you do
anything else because listen
i you can say what you want me to do and
i i can follow suit i can happily follow
suit but if you're looking after my
every move or whatever you don't trust
me why am i going to be with you you're
saying you're basically saying it's how
i say and not what i say
is basically if i come to you and say
babes i don't really agree with like you
know what i'm saying don't i'm that's
not really necessarily what i said it's
better than saying babes i don't want
you to do that no no no no no no and i'm
saying okay i'm not saying how to say it
a couple establishes their relationship
listen to what i'm saying let me learn
let me let me learn i'm not saying how
to say it i'm just saying
there's certain boundaries in the
relationship with me that you could
either adhere to and you could be with
me or you could not adhere to and be
free as a bird but if you're with me
you're gonna you're gonna be doing
certain rules yeah and i expect that if
you if you are a woman that that is of
some cloth that you're going to have
some rules that i have to stand by as
well i'm not just i can't just be
willy-nilly doing things that i want to
do because if i want to do what i want
to do i'll be around chatting to every
girl i want to
okay
but like there'll be no restrictions but
i'm saying you never went against what
you said because what i said is they're
going to agree on these boundaries
together so yes yes it's a level of
compromisation if you acknowledge my
boundaries but i never said i i said
[ __ ] your boundaries i said we're going
to agree together so if you're saying
i'm going to if not because listen i
already said if for me i think the man
should be the leader like that's the
traditionally the man is the leader of
the relationship
so
huh no sorry good
but
so
whatever whatever rules we're setting up
in place
i
in theory i'm saying i would agree to
them because i said they're coming
together and agreeing on this i never
said that the girl is saying f you and
everything that you're saying i'm not
going to listen to you you're not my
parent blah blah blah i said they're
going to agree together so you can still
be the leader and i can agree by your
rules i think the skills are more tipped
in the favor of girls in in terms of how
it is in terms of the relationships that
men and women
because you're allowed to wait on
whatever you want but the man is
restricted and what's basically in and
other men okay so in the sense of this
other men
like will restrict other men
in terms of okay
i get what you're saying men will men
will
check a man before a woman checks a
woman one of them
we're
we're more so
we're more so beans that
like it's it's been said multiple times
on the channel like oh someone asked
like if i asked the girls do i look fat
in this dress nine times out of ten
they're like no girl you think you look
good
and then if i asked a guy friend they'd
be like um yeah or if a guy has hey like
how does this fit look and if it looks
trash they're gonna be like go change go
change that but a woman would be like no
i think if you put some shoes with it
it'll look good
so yeah
is that it's just i think that's more
speaking to them that's more on a
biological standpoint like guys are just
naturally more
um straight to the yeah there's a
straight to the point like we're not
there's no need to cap about two ways
where fema are more like if you've got a
problem then you probably won't know all
you will know and no words have been
said
the problem comes hidden hostility
between every problem
though
the problem comes when men are talking
to women because we're straightforward
you don't want a hair straight forward
so should women
so what you're saying is women should
learn to understand how men talk so they
can receive it yeah
because that's part of their feminine
energy like guys we're masculine we can
take that girls don't have a lot of
masculine energy unless she's just
naturally masculine there's masculine
females out there but um but even at
that as a feminine girl or feminine
person like you're gonna take you're
gonna feel a tap away like it's gonna
hit you differently but if you're a guy
and you've got masculine energy you're
not gonna feel the same type of way so
for you to say a guy should now convert
to being a masculine bro if she does
that and she starts developing more
masculine traits you're not going to
like it in the long run no no i'm not
going to say that she should develop a
message no i'm just going along with
what jess was saying she said
girls should understand how men
communicate yeah communicate and speak
how do you understand how a person
communicates
if i want to talk spanish i would have
to learn how to talk spanish no no no
therefore if i
was like spanish
a feminine person i'll learn how i'll
have to learn how to communicate more
family-like so that they can understand
check this check this now yeah if your
girl's upset now yeah and and um she
says ah which dr like her answer which
just should i read this um this one or
that one or um i want to go hey i want
to go there and a guy's comment says oh
we just got to do this one that's like
oh no this is that oh she's mad i'll
she'll turn it into a next thing for you
to destabilize that situation there you
can't come on a masculine aggro flex
like ah um why are you doing this
no you gotta find a way to neutralize
her energy dan
things are civil
to girls like men that are indecisive
about where they're taking their goals
thank you there's no indecisive there no
i'm saying okay the man the man taking
charge is in response to women saying we
don't like men that are indecisive about
this but what i'm trying to say is how
do you take charge it's not about
getting taking charges taking place yeah
is that how you take charge i get that
but what i'm trying to say to you
certain girls like certain things bro
not every girl is the same
okay
we're assuming that every girl is the
same every girl is not the same some
girls like men to take charge yeah some
some girls might see a man taking charge
as a man being controlling
certain girls might not see it as
controlling they might just say my man's
taking charge but he knows what to do he
knows to handle it i don't need to do
nothing i'm just here chilling brother i
don't live in my reader
i don't disagree with your point
there's no dis i'm taking charge in
place i'm saying is how you take charge
exactly what your point is you said
certain girls might like this and
certain girls might like that it's how
you take charge and how it applies to
the girl that you're dealing with i want
you to elaborate there's a fine line
isn't there there's a fine line if
you're entering into any kind of
relationship with someone it's about
understanding how they are and then
understanding how you are setting some
some as you say boundaries but within
those boundaries there's compromise any
partnership whether it be a relationship
a friendship there's always going to be
compromise like you might not like
something they do you not you might not
like some and vice versa you know so
it's about understanding and working
together if you really like someone
you'll make it work because at the end
of the day we're all different but you
cannot we cannot be telling people what
to do we can't do that it's not our
right to tell someone what to do but
what we can say is do you know what i'm
not too happy about that
and then we can work on it together oh i
agree with that
chill bro sure i agree with that i agree
with that but
i don't think i don't think it is
telling somebody what to do i don't
think it's that at all fab me i would
never tell anybody what to do yeah if
you want to because remember
women control sex men control
relationships right so if you want to be
in a relationship with me
you have to speak to them you have to
abide by my house rules you understand
how everyone everyone has house rules
cool you're coming in as the vice
president of this house call me you can
send your house
you're sergeant you can set your advice
you can set up some of the rules that
you want as well do you understand what
you want
michelle obama i'm the president for
barack obama i'm the president here if
you want a relationship with me you have
to come on my flex and that's cop if you
don't if you don't that's fine
absolutely that's why i was saying that
when you start this relationship is for
both of you to agree it's not that the
woman is not gonna like say i'm the
leader is that you're both agreeing to
the terms of whatever that's why that's
why sorry can i just finish so you can't
say to someone you can't say to someone
as well
you've got to delete your instagram what
we need to understand is why you're
saying can you delete your instagram and
get to the core routine yeah yeah what
is the issues there is it because
previously something's happened to
traumatize you with this you can't it's
not funny you're getting you're guessing
me because i'll say this
instagram is one of the biggest dating
sites in the world right now
hold on better finish let her finish
can i finish right into i do agree and
i've been cheated on through instagram
but that doesn't mean that i would say
to someone that i'm pursuing delete your
instagram because you want to build
trust there you you can't control what
someone does you need to let people and
allow people to have the flexibility to
be who they want to be and the true
colors will come from that you have to
have trust if you put boundaries up by
saying
and when i say boundaries is controlling
that and saying you can't do this that's
not a relationship that is a
dictatorship you need to have the trust
there
is a relationship honest
if your brother was a thief would you
leave him in your room with all your
money and jewels and stuff with you
alone
just yes or no would you would you like
yes or no if your brother if your
brother was a thief your brother was a
thief you love your brother so
no no i'm asking her your brother is a
thief your brother yeah you love him you
admire him you've seen him grow up
you've watched him you you know i'm
saying you are cute together when you go
out to fun fairs that's your brother
would you leave him the thief in a room
with your stuff your money inside the
open safe but what you're saying here is
comparing it to someone who's previously
cheated and then i'm getting in a
relationship with them who's cheated on
instagram no no listen because you are
because you're saying your brother's a
thief and you're leaving him alone so
you're there is
a comparison is saying you're dating
someone who's previously cheated are you
going to allow them to have instagram
that's what you're saying no that's not
that's not what i'm saying that's not
what i'm saying at all it is you've
created a you've shifted the goal post
to say what i'm saying how if you're if
you haven't done the brother
elaborate yes or no question and what
she's done instead of allowing me to
elaborate how i wanted to to where i've
seen
yes or no would you leave your thief
brother
inside of a room with all your you're
safe open with all your money in it it's
not a yes or no can i say thank you very
much so
so there's a problem there's there's
there's a issue that you're having
between yourself where you're fired in
between trusting your brother or between
leaving the thief brother inside of a
room with your your safe i'm saying to
you it's not that i don't trust you i'm
saying to you the the more that you are
available on instagram with the same
pics that you had when i saw you is
gonna be another man like me coming
after you and i'm saying okay if you
wanna have the for sale sign on the car
okay cool we could just be and i will
not take you seriously but if you want
me to take you seriously and get off the
game where i don't
bother no other girls i don't church no
girl i say listen i'm dedicated for you
you have to be dedicated for me your
your equivalent of me chirps and girls
is you being available to be chirps
can i ask you something i'm not saying
be locked in the house so i'm just
saying avoid certain things
hold up guys you made a very valid point
just like you know what i mean like you
you found her like that yeah and
what do you mean and that's what okay
that's gonna like the same kind of post
that attracted me to you yeah yeah
meaning that you found her like that
right so and you found in her like that
you accepted her like that as she is bro
she accepted you as a person that chirps
gal bro
so should you continue to gallop should
you should you continue
how would anyone get
let me speak let me speak that is so
unfair because again i am the one that's
chirping you so okay i'm gonna chirps
you yeah you're thinking i'm the first
you're the first person of chirps and
you're wait hold on hold on
as a girl are you what i think all right
i'll check all right i'll change it are
you thinking i'm you're the first person
i've churched yeah no i never i've never
trust anyone yeah i have no skill in
chirps in but i'm just so good at
chirping you that you like me
no so you think that i've been chasing
other girls right obviously obviously so
i'm thinking that you're being churched
by other men right because you're nice
you're beautiful right yes wait so
should i continue be you being available
or should i take you off the market